hi there steve kaufman here uh first of
all uh if you enjoy these uh discussions
about language learning please subscribe
to my
channel here at youtube
i also have a blog the linguist on
language and i'm going to be posting
within a day or two a short piece on the
whole area of error correction and
whether it's necessarily useful or not
with a reference to stephen krashen's uh
book on language acquisition and where
you can find it on the internet so check
out my blog the linguist on language
but today i want to talk about chinese
new year and i'm going to finish off
speaking in mandarin
but of course it's been chinese new year
started a few days ago
and we're in palm springs there's no
decent chinese restaurants here if we
were in vancouver my wife and i would go
out and have chinese food
uh the chinese zodiac or the chinese new
year uh you know many of you may know
that it's based on this sort of cycle of
12
signs
and i happen to be a rooster or chicken
depending on your point of view
and so every 12 years the rooster comes
up so i kind of just for fun i wrote
down here you know my life as seen in
these
12-year snapshots so i was born in 1945
in sweden 12 years later i was in grade
7 i guess or seven or eight in school in
montreal
in english
of course
and then in 69 i had just completed my
year of chinese uh mandarin language
learning in hong kong started going in
and out of china
as a canadian trade commissioner
12 years later in 1981 i was working for
a major uh canadian lumber exporting
company in tokyo by that time i had
learned chinese
12 years later
1993 i had already started my own
company in uh
the you know lumber trade and we were
selling wood from north america to japan
from europe to japan so i was using my
japanese and i was also
very much into my swedish and german
because we were
either sourcing wood there or selling
wood into those countries
10 years later 2005
is more or less or 12 years later rather
2005 at the age of 60 is more or less
when i begin uh learning russian which
has
been a tremendous adventure for me
and i had just come back from promoting
my book in china because we did have a
chinese version of this so i was able to
give speeches to people in you know
different universities and so forth in
china so that's 2005 at the age of 60.
and here i am uh in my 72nd year more or
less retired but still very much
committed to link and committed to
language learning working right now on
my four slavic languages uh having just
completed a
challenge with uh korean so i'll try and
kind of cover the same ground in chinese
since it is chinese new year
[Music]
palm springs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you